a popular veteran's home right here in
the valley is now under new management
after a rough patch had its residents
just in the dark now the former sheriff
village site is turning a new leaf and
even has a new identity
a little bit of time a new air is
underway at the former share village
site some who live there like robert
holloway say the new leadership brings
hope to those who have lost so much it's
definitely a different feeling it really
is when you actually have people that
will listen to you you know and address
your needs holloway adds it's the hard
work karidad's executive director
meredith spriggs has done to turn the
place around since she took charge last
november even changing the name to
hebron i want this to be a bright spot
in downtown not only for
the people that live here but the
community i want this to be a community
gathering place and i want this to be a
resource for months many veterans at
this las vegas boulevard property say
they were in limbo after arnold stock
stepped back from his share village
operation duties last summer due to
health reasons spriggs signed the lease
with property owners ysb investments and
quickly got to work we had over 40
vacant rooms but they were not up to
code so what we've been doing is we've
been working on leasing up but also
bringing the rooms up to code some of
the people couldn't flush their toilets
today 15 of the 125 units have been
completely remodeled with new carpet
paint and furniture a long road ahead
but already lifting spirits put in a
little bit of effort i appreciate it and
i'm sure most arrested people here
appreciate it
it's a good thing well spriggs says they
are working to add more programs and
services but as you can imagine that
takes funding and physical labor so if
you're interested in donating or just
becoming a volunteer check out our
website eightnewsnow.com for all the
details and you've been following them
for quite some time now christian nice
update there